hi monica hey so we've all spent more
time
in front of the screen during the
pandemic whether that's because of you
know work from home watching tv
just to pass the time but ladies and
gentlemen for our kiddos it has not been
a good thing
and i'm sorry to say that especially for
those of us whose children
are continuing to learn virtually but i
have a remedy for you his name is dr
nelson lopez he is a local pediatric
eye specialist and he also is a doctor
for
adults as well my husband and my son go
to dr lopez so i can vouch
for his credentials dr lopez thank you
so much for being here how you doing
absolutely monica thank you for having
me you're doing well thank you okay
so listen um delano took d'artagnan to
see you and he comes back and he says dr
uh lopez wants to talk to you because
there's something affecting kids who are
doing virtual learning
tell all of our parents what's happening
and what we need to do to combat it
well the past year of virtual learning
has been a very different environment
for the kids and what i am seeing
over the past year is a significant
spike in the number of children who are
complaining about
dry eye symptoms and those mainly would
be
eye pain redness tearing and even eye
fatigue after a long day
uh being on the computer so uh
definitely
all related to being on the computer for
six
sometimes eight even ten hours a day
yeah and doc is this something that will
affect children long term because you
know we're still dealing as adults with
the fallout from coven and everything
we've had to do
you know to just maintain our health is
it long term for our kiddos
well i feel that the onset of dry eye
symptoms at a younger age
will lead to these children and this
generation
really suffering from potentially severe
dry eye earlier on in adult life
so yes i believe there's long-term
impact okay so what do we do to
remedy that because i know a lot of
parents we're already stressed out about
taking care of our kids
we've missed appointments because of the
pandemic so how can we combat this how
can we make it better for our kiddos
the best way to combat this and the
kiddos never like hearing this
recommendation
is to reduce the amount of screen time
absolutely no the amount of screen time
for school is absolutely necessary yeah
but i've asked
parents to reduce or eliminate if
possible the use of devices
after school is finished and with the
pandemic ongoing
fewer activities that are um allowable
at this point
but hopefully loosening here in the next
several months
kids are having to use devices video
gaming computers
youtube those sorts of things for
entertainment and i understand their
lack of enthusiasm when it's recommended
that they're
no longer using the screens yeah but
you're the expert and you're also a
parent so uh we're taking this to heart
believe me what about the kids
like my son dartanian he wears glasses i
know there are other children
in his age group they wear contacts so
what about those kids is it better or
worse for them
well contact lenses will always lead to
dry eyes
and in this environment where children
are staring at a computer
and at times maybe not blinking within
30 to 60 seconds
yeah their eyes are suffering and these
this is where the
symptoms of dry eye are starting so yes
contact lens wearers
will potentially have more symptoms
earlier on
all right dr lopez if parents want to
get in contact with you how do they do
so because again you are
an ophthalmologist for parents i mean
for adults and for children right
that is correct yes we see patients of
all ages
from young to adults and they can just
contact the office
lopez eye institute the phone number is
725-266-4840
all right now you know during commercial
break this is what john and alex were
alluding to ladies and gentlemen every
time i've interviewed dr lopez
like i said i've known him for years i
get calls and emails from women asking
if he's single i'm just putting it out
there
he's not single he is married and he has
two beautiful children
and he is not available and yes we know
he looks like the rocky you ought to see
him in person
okay doc before we wrap it up you know
you got to do the thing
i have to do the thing you have to do
the thing yeah you ready
i'm ready
[Laughter]
that's the right that's the best i can
do
it's not doing him any justice but
that's the best i can do
oh you do him justice every time my
friend he'd be proud thank you so much
dr lopez
all right have a wonderful day all right
you too
see yeah yeah and don't forget folks hey
catch the mlj show facebook live we are
doing something really
cool tonight so make sure to tune in uh
you know the harmony
uh arm of the mlj show it's our charity
arm hope and relief mission we have
collaborated with
the emerald dream foundation you saw
them right here on the show we
interviewed them well guess what our
collaboration paid off
and we're going to showcase the first
person in our las vegas community
that has received help as a result of
our collaboration we're so proud of this
and she happens to be a local veteran
tune in at 7 pm for the moj show
facebook live